we got the tools of death to the size
this [ __ ] the magazine is [ __ ] with
no label honey you came on a good night
we got a little [ __ ] strawberry
cheesecake and this is for a friend
don't worry about nothing you know thing
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
and by the way we eat these and I
[ __ ] sleep you're following me Liz
are we showing up with the night the
blood [ __ ] purple wants [ __ ] you
see what I'm talking about
you want to [ __ ] around [ __ ] around with
your friends you come on the church this
is the real deal Mongolia feel cuz
you're all I've got
tonight oh [ __ ] you're all I've got
tonight oh [ __ ] there's what I'm talking
about and we've got a little nicotine
gum to throw in there you know I'm
saying just when you thought it was
[ __ ] safe
Rochester without [ __ ] you bad
[ __ ] you Lisa ants he's got a
mug on and he knows he's dying tonight
you know it's all over
zipper critical nothing in zipper crew
that hasn't called he's in no danger
he's in no [ __ ] dangerous
[Music]
oh [ __ ] that's the type of night whip
talk on the body on the church [ __ ]
[Music]
fire you bad [ __ ]
[Music]
is what I'm talking about
tell grandmother go to bed you're
lighting the house on fire tonight if we
can do it so can you
they won't give you them 20 years for us
and time you fell asleep Lee joint your
mouth and I'm saying it happens all the
time to America Danny Lee go [ __ ]
the smoke of love are you [ __ ]
kidding me or what if you're under 18
hang up now [ __ ] we're going deep
deep in the murky waters to safety eight
great [ __ ] dance and I don't give a
[ __ ] about your views you little young
[ __ ] you don't know dick about
date or you know is [ __ ] up how to
[ __ ] your teacher and go home and tell
your mom in the middle of night you
little [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
there we go we gotta chase the bad
spirits out [ __ ]
uncle Joey's here tonight you little
[ __ ] and we're doing our date
we're doing our thing so I hope you
never do yours if you don't want a party
with the big boys get off the [ __ ]
scope of life [ __ ] because what's
coming at you even worse now this reefer
I got is gonna get you high through the
telescope of [ __ ] the Internet you
follow me what the [ __ ] are you talking
about [ __ ]
one minute I'm with my daughter watching
Bruce Lee movies the next minute were in
the Voodoo Lounge pushing the [ __ ]
limits of THC dumb you follow me uncle
Joey here welcoming you [ __ ] to
another fun-filled evening we're waiting
for our guests now but in the meantime
you know we do our thing cuz it don't
stop [ __ ] you gotta open up with the
wet but let the [ __ ] well you think i'ma
show up with a Bible
what you think please think I'm Harvey
Weinstein I'm showing up with the heavy
artillery [ __ ] oh [ __ ] good
googling movie and you guys thought this
would be a boring Monday night suck my
dick and call me shorty I was born in
1940 BAM two down twenty two more to go
I hope you're in the [ __ ] mood today
because I'm about to stab a [ __ ]
please sit in that trembling he looks
like one of John wicks victims we're
going deep in them and look at they're
all twins they're all tools just
thinking throwing snake eyes you know
I'm saying I'm throwing snake eyes like
a [ __ ] here cuz I got sucker if
you're under 18 hang up that phone right
now I don't wanna hit Oh [ __ ]
stories you miserable [ __ ] get your
[ __ ] together it's a new week with a new
set of rules if you were thinking of
coming to the Gotham you're [ __ ] out of
luck
it's so dark [ __ ] do
now and Dean that way still hummed
weakness throwing salt in your wounds
like one of the [ __ ] punches pilots
men what the [ __ ] is wrong with him I'm
saying
Dean stop it go somewhere sing a song
[ __ ] anyway you're lucky we're
here it's a good Monday night I'm
feeling tip-top Magoo all the pieces
fell in place today
not that they fell in place I've been
working on them and that's how things
fall into place you got to work on them
you just don't wake up and look [ __ ]
itchy you got to get up [ __ ] you
gotta focus who gives a [ __ ] about who
ward or whatever if you ain't getting
paid on that game go [ __ ] yourself you
shouldn't be there everybody wants to go
to heaven but nobody wants to die it's
time to sub dick like those actresses
they all suck dick and see where it got
him they got Oscars what do you got got
something and you don't want to suck a
dick lighten up and here's my trusted
little [ __ ] Jewish friend my little
crazed killer friend ready to do more
[ __ ] bong hits than [ __ ] Cheech
without child you follow me it's just
another pattern my my love
shooting bombs like [ __ ] Hitler's
men's hit what should we get [ __ ]
leave first let's give them what nobody
knows you don't say oh [ __ ]
somebody's coming knocking and it ain't
the [ __ ] whatever do young Sam this
is the stomach get out you're doing your
warmups
let's do you got more spots than [ __ ]
when I make it what happened to you
now don't blame it on that you are
spotty when I got in the air kind of
sucker
you only have one star you go this
[ __ ] got more spots on the
[ __ ] whatever going deep into the
metaphor life tonight with some other
guy there you go now with now we're
talking doctor beliefs beep left that
[ __ ] belly button hit your spine
there you go tip your head back let the
blood go into the back of your brain and
now we go for [ __ ] broke here there
you go your neck there you go that's the
one you've been waiting for all weekend
that's the one hold on hold on that's
the one you were waiting for all weekend
that's the one that's the one that's the
one Santa Claus section that's the one
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
smooth like Sunday morning and I'm
saying smooth like Sunday [ __ ]
morning people that's the kind of [ __ ]
we're throwing here how many stars eat
so far let's get these [ __ ] TKOs
ready who's ready good detail
[Music]
Dean Delray weed right there oh my god
what the [ __ ] he drifts stuff on his
weed guys that's not just weed he
liquefies pills and drips you can see
it's like a science experiment there's
tubes and smoke weed I'm trying to tell
you [ __ ] this [ __ ] I'm getting
here these numbers I'm giving you dog I
could but yeah I'm saying this your
uncle Joey that the [ __ ] numbers I'm
giving you will blow your [ __ ]
eyeballs out last night I smoked some
[ __ ] I was embedded [ __ ] tendril I
had to get up at 11:00 and wipe my
[ __ ] face
with the sleep apnea master their old
Cheetos in there is [ __ ] Wayne [ __ ]
around me you want to [ __ ] around [ __ ]
around on your own but if you want to
get down you gotta come to the Voodoo
Lounge [ __ ] anyway it's time
[ __ ] chitterchat we want to talk
about it you want to talk about see a
counselor his uncle Joey [ __ ] the [ __ ]
is wrong with you people
BAM we get these little brothers and
they're like but an uncle Joey even over
the hotel they give you these no [ __ ]
things and they're cheap it's like a
[ __ ] it's like one of those Chinese
ladies pimples
look at this comes right out of the
[ __ ] thing yeah you people think I'm
[ __ ] around I got grease all over my
fingers
it's like finger banging somebody with a
yeast infection look at this [ __ ]
thing look at this [ __ ] cake
[Music]
bone up a deep [ __ ] the
magician of life has just shrunk into
your [ __ ] world uncle and your Nadine
hang up now
don't be [ __ ] around as I said to
ruff stood by the CIA it's 180 brothels
men it's so tough it's so tough on you
fellows
[Music]
life's the same it's all inside you
oh [ __ ]
now guys I ain't [ __ ] around we've
been hanging for a long time whatever is
in this [ __ ] tool is supersonic
you should have [ __ ] seen it was scary
you'll get weed on you in and you're
like what the [ __ ] is this this is a
smoke and [ __ ] March I don't give a
[ __ ] you know me guys I take a look at
it I'm scared like [ __ ] 30 seconds
then I think beep until the nutsack of
life like oh [ __ ] it after what I've
been through what some [ __ ] bomb
they're gonna do now we're still here
slinging dick every day pushing
[ __ ] gotta keep pushing who
gives a [ __ ] what they think it's not
what they think it's what you think [ __ ]
them
I don't give a [ __ ] you think I worried
about these [ __ ] people in California
Hollywood or something like dick at the
end I've done the [ __ ] heavy lifting
is my main man and show [ __ ] the two
killers of death walked in together
[Music]
[ __ ] yeah you know we look for these
family
what's up beautiful that he is the Man
of Steel good as a [ __ ] there
you go
Lexington Kentucky we're gonna be
talking about this [ __ ] tonight as long
as long as you guys are good I'm good
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
let me gotta copy this to show these
[ __ ] what it really looks like
will it really be looking like now how
many dates you got left on this poor boy
I saw that I'm like wait a second maybe
Phoenix
[Music]
all right give it to me let me tell
these guys on periscope real quick my
brother's here mr. Walker
all right we got December 3rd at the
Novo in Los Angeles but write it down
grab a [ __ ] plan don't look at me
like that
December 4th San Diego at the
observatory in North Park December 5th
Santa Ana another observatory after they
show you to look at the [ __ ] stars
whatever the [ __ ] you want to do and
December 6 you ready for this one
Phoenix at the van Buuren these are my
brother
we love warped a Junius dates get out
there and see what some real [ __ ]
country [ __ ] looks like he gets some
all sizes fat one big ones long-legged
one's country [ __ ] [ __ ] not
that little [ __ ] by your house it smells
like a petunia you don't need that [ __ ]
country [ __ ] smells like diesel and
Budweiser you follow man you got in that
monkey you like I'm home [ __ ]
anyway youtube.com slash c / Joey Diaz
is the place to be not this night
tomorrow night next Tuesday at o'clock
me and the Augustine are you ready
you [ __ ] want it you got it
Netflix showcase I need you down there
I need 9,000 people down there stabbing
people like that football game is a
football game yesterday
people were smacking each other I need
that type of activity if you're gonna
come to the show with that tight back -
that's what we need
we need to come down and show what the
church is all about it seats 90 but we
need 900 we'll put speakers out dirty
minutes Leoben is only two thousand
milligrams I would be if I was you -
then you thinking to yourself what am I
gonna do for [ __ ] Thanksgiving I'll
tell you what the other night before
Thanksgiving there comes the Irvine
improv eight o'clock the Agostino back
lineup we will walk the plane the [ __ ]
ukulele I don't give a [ __ ]
Irvine improv that one day right before
Thanksgiving - get up bring a kilo of
coke we got narcos we got a whole time
Jota no listen don't matter youtube.com
/ c / Joey Diaz
we will walk the juniors here we got
time to [ __ ] around
arrivederci boys mommy my finger
let me suck my dick in Cuba